this is a National Emergency the native
charged
[Music]
as soon as I read the script I'm putting
the pieces together in my mind
[Music]
we started talking about different
approaches and different types of
musical ideas the film School grew very
organically very gradually from the
smallest elements and I had no
preconceptions about the music for the
film sometimes you have an idea for the
soundscape of the world the rhythm of it
and sometimes you don't and in this case
all I had that I gave a little bit was
the idea of basing the score on the
violin
[Music]
there's so much in the performance of
the violin within seconds you can go
from Something Beautiful to something
completely horrifying and there's a
tension to the sound in a way that I
think fits the highly strong intellect
and emotion of Robert Oppenheimer very
well
and that's just the organic part of it
that's just the strings and then what
comes on later is the production and the
synthesizers
foreign
I think every process of scoring is
different if it's to be tailored
correctly to the demand of a new project
and and this was a type of film I hadn't
made before and it was type of music
that hadn't worked with before
a lot of things to do in the beginning
is about experimenting and see where you
can take things we would take his
experiments and we would put them to
picture and edit them and try different
things and show it to the league and he
would go and bring more things to the
table
Oppenheimer is a visual Masterpiece you
know I never seen that kind of intimate
portrayal of a character on IMAX that's
uh that's the sixth note Oppenheimer
theme I felt like this movie was really
pushing the boundaries in so many
different fields so I wanted to see how
we can do that with music as well
[Music]
I think Ludwig's work on the film is
both deeply personal and historically
expansive I think it really achieves an
enormous amount of the effect of drawing
the audience into the emotional dilemmas
of the characters I think he's really
put together a very remarkable School
[Music]